Christmas stuff is coming out earlier
and earlier and earlier it used to be
the sacred thing that there were no ads
about Christmas until after Thanksgiving
now they start yeah it starts in October
yeah sometimes late summer they're like
you know you got to get your Christmas
[ __ ] together you know what I mean yeah
I don't see a problem I you I actually
do genuinely love it you like it I do
like I love Christmas music and I love
the feel of Christmas
I've already started Christmas shopping
I mean I literally I love it I wait til
the night before I go to a 7-eleven and
everyone gets slim jims that's what
happens in my house like why don't take
it slims yeah and this burrito for the
freezer you can have it later I have a
question now you have two very young
children are they into Santa Claus no oh
you guys this is really funny so I don't
know hopefully no kids are watching this
spoiler alert however oh my god I know
I'm sorry Andy I'm so sorry
it's okay
tell your story tell your story it's not
even a story this is real life I have a
three-year-old my love a month old is 11
months so he doesn't really care can
tell that kid anything yeah yeah he's
just like a little bit of a blob and
he's a boy so he's you know a little
delayed yeah but I love him my little
girl she's three and she's so smart and
so logical that she couldn't understand
the concept of why is a strange man you
know in a in a suit coming down our
chimney I don't know him why do I have
to be nice to him why are we feeding him
and why can't I see him and I was like
these are all really good questions yeah
and let's talk to Daddy and then and
then it was Easter when she was asking
the question about about Santa and we
realized she is really scared of all
things plushie like she's definitely not
gonna have a fetish of plushies like um
like you know yeah like people wearing
furry suit getting it on yeah it's not
gonna have that problem yeah she is
frightened of anything in a big furry
suit I think first of all that's good
that's good that you can safely that
your child do not be into that but
second I think what's why shouldn't a
child be frightened of weird
it's a bearded stranger who comes into
your home at night yeah to root around
and do stuff it's it's not cool it's not
good I know and then top of that ass
tonight we're like oh let's make it
magical for her
so we why I don't know put um like flour
on the bottom of his boots and stomp the
boots around the house but like look
santa came and he brought snow with him
and she came rush because why is there
dust everywhere like it didn't she's too
logical you know fine then she's like
yeah
Santa's got a cocaine problem
since messed up
[Applause]
you